hola [ __ ] least our soy lista we're
back Wow
yeah that one we're bad baby I'm back
good afternoon [ __ ] good morning good
night no wait not good night yet we're
not done no so this is Gio the main
[ __ ] okay well this is Gina I can also
say I mean [ __ ] of my life I want to be
a side veggies on the side over here on
the left side [ __ ] this is just the
middle bit
hey uh in this is Bo's I would describe
myself as the ancillary [ __ ] what does
that mean it means I am needed but not
the main oh the lynchpin okay I want to
it's like you read she's educated yeah
well at [ __ ] I can I can I can read all
I'm doing mic thing again and I know
you're doing the mic thing because you
know what we're talking about today
babies today we're talking about some
fantasy fetishes fantasy oh yeah dishes
yes yeah I so this whole time I was like
kind of not reading it that's not the
right word but I was just kind of like
oh dang what no not nervous but I'm like
what am I going to talk about cuz I've
been married I've been I've been with
bar for like almost 11 years now and
like I'm like [ __ ] what am i what am i
fantasies one of my fetishes and I
didn't think I had anything who but I
came up with some in my head I'm like
there they are I can't wait to hear your
guys's okay cool y'all go ahead first
take some time we can warm up I'm gonna
I'm gonna start off I got a PowerPoint
my fantasy that I always go to and I'm
just gonna say it
I have a fantasy about having sex with a
man I love on my honeymoon you [ __ ]
losers I'm serious I [ __ ] told you
you're not an ancillary or Inserra Tori
what did you say yes Hillary you ain't
that I am ancillary I'm just starting it
off soft and I am soft ready B song you
know what you're right cuz actually like
a lot of people don't have a marriage
they don't have a man that they love
they don't have like good sex so like
even just getting to the point of being
married yes
like some depressed right now video
Hardbody quantum so Gio's living your
fantasy right now lady mud you know when
we did that when we did that episode
where did you like about nudes when
wouldn't you I was like oh my favorite
part is what they say back and I'm like
usually if I send a photo about guys
like nice and like there's only Gio like
oh you're my [ __ ] Wonder Woman I want
to rip your I don't know saying yeah
they're probably saying that but it's
cuz they're threes you know what I mean
Oh newts to three because I mean I got
it boost my ego oh okay that's fair
because no else are they gonna get they
can't leave anyone after this dull I
think that's a valid fantasy and it goes
I'm not hitting it goes beyond sexuality
it's it's very just feels like you're
lying that's I know I know did your
Gravatt hole goes detour Christians you
know I want to go down the rabbit hole
well I'm just kick-starting it oh let's
consider that a level two in the world
okay fine it's a level zero oh my god a
level one okay I got level one I one of
my fantasies is to be picked up and
[ __ ] against the window that's all
yeah that's a good no y'all used to live
in a [ __ ] place with floor C we know
we had really bad sex in that apartment
like sex life at that moment okay okay
okay
are you so scared that we would bang
through the window and through the glass
good way to die well you know how to
have a good time too scary for me
oh that's another one dude I I think
I've got a level three but I need
somebody to throw in a level two okay I
know yeah look [ __ ] the cop you got some
it's just like [ __ ] in public a level
three I think so level two that's a
little - oh that is it but we're in
public
yeah we're like worse well like I have
like in a parking garage like somewhere
where there's a lot of people come in
now
that's a level three that well that's -
we went zero one okay okay so you have a
three damn me man y'all went we're gonna
give you three then okay if [ __ ] in
public is a - I think I have a four oh
no one has a [ __ ] thing okay three
threesomes four three with two dudes
that's three that's mine I had two three
I think our scales are a little bit off
I don't want this one as my fantasy but
maybe one of you [ __ ] might like
kissing a chick no that's level high
school if that's I don't wanna see for a
girl that doesn't have any balls yeah
for a Christian girl at a Christian high
school yeah just sorry Christian girls
that are gorgeous for a girl that's
lesbian bi or pan that hasn't gotten to
yet mmm okay fantasy I guess walk the
number three we don't give a [ __ ] about
no we need a number three well we can't
get past it we one of you guys has a
level three deep in there somewhere
um [ __ ] this is a horrible [ __ ] air
man this is still okay that's my level 3
I love to get the [ __ ] choked out of me
Oh like the [ __ ] like well thank you no
I like to get my [ __ ] [ __ ] choked out
like I like I like to get choked out no
[ __ ] we don't do no scat stuff no thank
you it's cold s'ghetti it's CAF guys I
thought Scott was wrong Family Matters
[ __ ] [ __ ] gettin ready to start
throwing another eye I can't tell if you
guys are half
or we were in between episodes I was
just drinking patron it's okay well you
know what we're on the same level but no
but different yeah okay what number aim
but different okay so our yeah
wait level zero was intimate intimacy
and intimate sexual encounter okay
number one was that's you number one
number one was getting [ __ ] against
the window Oh getting [ __ ] against
someone no a little a little a little
assertion Allah dominance see but I feel
like that the five but yeah I think it's
the one then I'm prude then we had level
two which would be [ __ ] in a public
ways that has heavy foot traffic yeah
I've gotten a couple of those and then
next we've got choking yeah it's
dangerous that's my [ __ ] dude I it's
like a light switch for me like if you
ever like if my man and I are in public
we can be at a [ __ ] funeral for my
grandmother he just like man he just if
he grabs my neck I'm like you [ __ ] me
on that casket right now it's a light
switch it's like my like number one
thing Gina gets in a fight with another
girl no I think I'm losing this fight
okay so my weight we're number five no
four zero one two three is joking for
now alright
mine is okay here's a weird one I'm
gonna give you guys a weird one but I'm
not embarrassed about it okay okay I
have this weird thing and I guess it's
like a sensory deprivation blindfold or
one that's a-- for earplugs and
blindfold blindfold yeah and like tied
up yeah oh yeah so essentially it's
being deprived of like all control in
all senses and being left with only the
feeling do they plug your nose too no no
can't smell any oh I can smell
everything look for smell you're gonna
smell everything like your smell your
sense of smell is gonna get Titans
you're gonna like smell the [ __ ] [ __ ]
he didn't wipe off his ass crack I
literally can't smell anything this
that's never happened before dick has a
smell girl oh it does so does [ __ ]
but it doesn't it doesn't get heightened
that much oh I'm turning to like a puppy
or anything but yeah but I mean like
yeah that's I think that's my that's
almost like one of mine I think it's a
little higher I am totally Billy we
gotta go with the five five is a devil's
threesome
yeah - guys guys there's - dig oh oh
okay wait who wants that me yeah oh okay
[ __ ] yeah yeah I want to experience my
first DP do you think that most guys
would be opposed to a devil's threesome
yes yeah yeah that most guys are I heard
her oh no no who I heard it from I feel
like it's one of you [ __ ] but I heard
that you can feel the guys like not that
you guys have had in the walls through
the grapevine yeah you could fuel their
dicks touching and they're like dicks
touching the only guys that I yes oh
very true we're gonna have to ask you
guys let us know in the comments if
you've been the only no not can you feel
it let me do it there's only a couple of
guys that I know would be down to do it
because they told me and they're like a
little bit like experimental with other
dudes - yeah yeah so for mine I don't
want DP I just want two guys in this
what's the difference between the oh I
don't want anything going up my ass like
ever
Oh like not even with my husband what is
he doing well he's there and I was like
his dick or something like just be in
the room and we'll tell her that what
the [ __ ] I told our when the girls in
the middle bent over and the guy is
she's sucking on one dude's dick and the
other one's [ __ ] her ass and the
entire five the top and it's a good
Eiffel Tower
alright yeah that's good I like that I
think I've not that's not mine oh they
hold hands the a why I never seen that
but that's hilarious
okay
I think that's a good five who wants a
five you want the five no no the devil
Street oh you guys that's fine I'm done
one guy at a time yes
okay that's boring guys Jason Momoa is
it boring no it's one like really
[ __ ] twelve if it's two Jason Momoa
zhh I'm down yeah for the devil if it's
- Jason my boys I'm coming over and I'm
watching hey you two let me what record
that [ __ ] I'm gonna fear for your life
you're like [ __ ] five feet yeah I can
handle that yeah I will record that and
I will get like close-ups of everything
oh what's up what's a six um crazy [ __ ]
genius do you know you said you guys do
you mean you said you got some nasty
[ __ ] I think I have a 600 latex the
group chat is coming out Jake a new the
public really did yeah I would have
loved the [ __ ] that I used to party at
dude all the golf parties and latex
parties are you sick dad thanks for the
invite I didn't know you then sorry yeah
this out of six yeah any scares the [ __ ]
out of me so it's hot [ __ ] it well
when they cover their face wow the masks
like [ __ ] reverse sensory deprivation
type thing because I don't get to see
that yeah pretty crazy you know what
let's go ahead and that was the six
right yeah let's go ahead and insert for
number seven let's just put this in from
Nikki glory holes you want to suck a
random as dick huh she want yeah okay
she don't want to do it it's just a
fantasy yeah seven I think we what comes
first glory holes are gang bangs
[ __ ] gang bangs I think a glory holes
way crazier because you have no yeah
they were that dick is cuz you think a
glory hole is crazier than a game yeah
you know who's coming today that I I
think so I think so because I do like
some some some like like trucker dude
might be sticking his Choate in there
and what if his dick is really pretty
you don't know if he's pretty though who
cares I need to know oh okay alright I
think what are we at eight nine yeah oh
I think before we even get there guys
last week I almost lost my job
oh I'm sorry dude I kept hitting snooze
oh I'm not kidding I'm not kidding so I
got my Casper mattress two weeks ago and
there's two things that have changed hey
when I'm about to go to bed I literally
look at my bed and I'm like oh yeah
you're about to get it never looked at
your bed at night and been so so
freaking excited it's breathable it
stated like it helps you stay cool like
it's I'm obsessed I think I've never had
like a really good mattress before I'm
used to going to hotels and having a
good night's sleep and being like oh
that was really good and then I go home
to my miserable existence and now I have
it at home after that the other thing is
when you wake up in the morning you
don't want to leave you absolutely do
not want to get out of bed I consciously
made the decision to hit snooze three
times yeah you melt in it you are you
absolutely melted to it the other thing
is shipping on it is super easy you
don't have to worry about you know
getting a giant u-haul and bringing it
over it ships right to your door and
it's nice super convenient packaging and
you can try your Casper a hundred nights
free you're gonna get addicted after 30
or otherwise you get your money back if
you guys want to try Casper you can get
$100 towards a select mattress they have
I think three different models they have
affordable options they have more
high-end options and then they kind of
have some middle tier all sizes queen
twin king Cali King get whatever you
want and you can use our code this is
gonna be a little different you're gonna
go to the Casper dot-com slash hey girl
that's right that's Casper calm slash
hey girl and you get $100 off to a
mattress 100 days risk-free trial
delivered straight to your door and
convenient packaging and enjoy the best
sleep of your knife yes
I love those because you don't have to
hire people
move a big-ass mattress no you do it by
yourself I love it and it's like a very
slim packaging and don't forget to enter
code hey girl at checkout as well so it
is Casper calm slash hey girl but at
checkout enter hey girl as well alright
we're back
do you know were you gonna tell us your
number eight no wouldn't what's sweet so
sevens glory hole and that's Nikki's
right damn we're getting up there eight
or gangbangs right eight is a gangbang
what the [ __ ] yeah we're but I mean like
I think we should make eight a gangbang
so that nine and ten cuz like we gotta
share easier should well yeah we're
talking about things that we're into
number nine what we won't even do eight
eight is gaming oh is it well do that
I'm down a lot of women are into
gangbang porn I'm not sure why don't I
walk you but you would do that too like
would you be doing is they're not gonna
stick it in my [ __ ] like I'll you're
gonna try it Steve like I'm gonna tell
the gangbang when I first walk in it's
not going to my [ __ ] if it does my
heel is going in your chin is that a
challenge I like that you're wrong I
want to be used and abused and it'll be
dope yeah I put a lot of different dicks
yeah making out with different people
yeah yeah that's hot yeah like it's dope
because like you're the one girl and
you're getting all the attention you
only want men yeah this is this is one
of my fantasies is going to those like
masquerade parties where you don't see
anyone's face but everyone has to be a
[ __ ] model like I want nothing but
tens around me there's one there's an
event like that I got access to it oh
yeah okay we're mean it's a fantasy I
don't know that would be long right now
I was gonna say a nine would be like a
big swingers party that I've told you
guys about like I think I'll be dope
because I like being watched by a crowd
while I'm getting boned
but we run it before I've done it before
we would have nine be more like
cuckolding like oh that's not me
personally well I guess I'm just like
creating about personal yes
yeah yeah everything my personal stuff
okay I didn't air in the room no I don't
so that's that's theirs for tiffin case
no no
oh that's KC's thing yeah yeah there's
like a big swingers parties there's one
where they eat the admission starts at
$10,000 oh my if you get tens I might
pay that they're all models dude like
they're all so mad do they're like you I
don't get it what you're my ID but yeah
this event is it actually takes place in
LA and there's and they move to Germany
to and I became friends with the owner
so it's like the minimum is $10,000 I
think for a membership the highest is a
one-time payment of a million dollars
and this is like celebrity it's like
they've seen celebrities in there and
all the girls are [ __ ] models and
like third parties are [ __ ] dope like
every like it's beautiful makes it dope
there's a very strict dress code men in
tuxedos and women in whatever the [ __ ]
that like looks really sexy but it's
like it's like it's not like a cheap
little party like this is like a full-on
and a [ __ ] mansion I'm imagining eyes
wide shut
exactly it's exactly like that and they
have performers like sex performers and
like gorgeous masks and everything they
have girls as tables yes they do like
guys like have their feet on their backs
like oh my gosh it makes me nervous
though I love like I feel like if I paid
a million dollars for membership they're
gonna like put me into a room and
they're gonna bring like little children
in there so scares me it just makes my
[ __ ] heebie-jeebies because up this
is like a lot of rich people [ __ ] like
that and hmm
but yeah like I've been to a couple
swingers parties and that's like my [ __ ]
I love having people watching me and I
like watching people do yeah yeah it's
dope I've never seen covered at all uh
no but if they're like Gina darling from
YouTube all right but no like it'sit's
don't like everyone's very open and
they're like super cool and then they
take away all your cell phones like you
are not allowed to have any cell phones
whatever in there at all that would be
helpful yeah I wouldn't mind being
security at that right yeah just stand
there the only thing I haven't done is
I've never swung like I've never liked
bein another dude whatever like we've
never swung it was just I'm I'm more
into the voyeurism
hmm
Oh voyeurism I mean what if we just we
still have to figure out in 1910 what if
we just free flow a fantasy conversation
and then they decide on the last to that
like at the end of the episode okay yeah
at the tap into that brain because I can
get any crazy I have I have a really
specific one but I go I've been really
into um you know like a bunch of people
online think that I'm like a an escort
oh you bright because you're traveling
all the time traveling which makes her
own money dump [ __ ] and um one of my
one of my fantasies is like because I've
never like I've always wanted to kind of
fulfill that escort like well what would
it be like I want him to take me purse
shopping right and then buy me a really
nice purse and then when we get home
before I open it up he's like no you
have to work for it first and then he
[ __ ] me and he's like you want that
purse you [ __ ] me good or else I'm gonna
return it right now like I have to work
for it or even in a dressing room that'd
be [ __ ] like how bad do you want that
person like I want to be a hooker that's
awesome yeah I'd be like Nana wanted
that much similar to that in the sense
of like okay so like you said like oh I
kind of like wanted to be nuts what are
like I want to live that life yeah I
wish I could live more of like a
free-flowing like hookup life cuz Geo we
talked about this before okay I have
this fantasy you were like me and my
boyfriend or significant other husband
whatever we go to a bar or something and
we act like we don't know each other and
we meet in the bar and like we flirt and
we go home with each other that night
but it's kind of role-playing definitely
I like role-playing I think it's like
I've never really done it but I know for
a fact I'd be into it you know I've just
never really done it with anyone but
yeah like mine would be going to a bar I
like acting like we don't know each
other and like having like a little
conversation then going home together
and then each other that would be like
pretending to have a one-night stand
that's a lot of like pretending unlike
being what like the opposite of what you
are like you do your one-night stand me
being reduced to nothing but a bag and
some money right now I love it
I'm currently working on Bart because
all of you guys know Bart he there's no
middle ground to him it's like he's
either really soft little spoon baby
bear or he's like super macho
like in a punch through a window and
like pull the guy out of the car type
thing yeah but he doesn't know the
middle ground so when I when I'm like
please dominate me like I'm like so yeah
left my ass so [ __ ] hard I started
crying yes cuz I'm like I'm like oh yeah
slap my ass and then he did it and I was
like oh my god that was like [ __ ]
like I was getting punished yeah I'm
like what the fine I was crying though
but that would be my current fantasy
right now to be like like just let a
little ground oh I love that dude this
is one time I got hogtied and like this
and your feet like this yeah exactly
[ __ ] I got hogtied and like a thing in
my mouth to keep my mouth shut and he
said you [ __ ] stay there until I'm
ready for you and then he just left me
on his bed and like every once in a
while I would be laughing no I said like
after five minutes like what the [ __ ] no
because no no he didn't that long that
long he would come back it's like did I
say you can [ __ ] move and then he'll
smack my ass really hard like ever like
he'll grab my hair be like I didn't say
you can [ __ ] move that should scare
ya really if Joe did that to you no Joe
no I don't want to be hogtied and like
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] to every few minutes
I'm like I legit just got kidnapped like
what's happening yeah I like to feel
like my life is in [ __ ] danger I also
remember you saying you got you boot you
like blacked out one time yeah back at
one time cuz he took me so hard was dope
I came to I woke up to him [ __ ] me it
was awesome
and then there's you money when you woke
up yeah like a couple seconds later and
then there's this one time we're like I
am we were in a hotel room and I said
something like super smart ass to him
next thing you know he likes he's like
running towards me and he grabbed like
the the iron the iron in the hotel room
you know those extended extension cords
that you kind of pull out and then every
tracks oh yeah yeah he like pulled the
extension he's like get the [ __ ] over
here and then he ran towards me and then
like like threw me on the bed and tied
me up with an iron
I thought he you I thought he was about
to knock you out any other object
[ __ ] no yeah Gina branded like scoffs
just [ __ ] hot
everything but yeah I love she like that
look and then he would tied me up and
just use me that shit's dope but then
afterwards it's really in the kink
culture there's this thing called
aftercare where like if you go that hard
he has to like take care of you
afterwards and like untie you Billy are
you okay do you want some weed wrinkly
bundle you up and cuddle yeah I'm like
wondering how do you feel after that cuz
I'm like I would like oh my god have you
ever had the type of sex where like once
you're done and like you look at each
other and you're just like I can't
believe you did that [ __ ] yeah I make
eye contact you're just like oh no I
make four icons like oh damn I'm glad we
did that [ __ ] oh no I've had that kind
of sex what were you doing that made you
so um am I like bashful um I don't know
I forgot what we were doing but it was
one of those you were saying or
something amazing I can't believe we
just said yeah yeah maybe maybe it was
the first time I had anal or something
but I was just like oh [ __ ] how did it
get to here are we bad people yeah that
just happened okay it's just me I think
my other one okay this is a really weird
one but okay I feel like my oh that's
some really weird [ __ ] to us already
maybe surprised feel like mine is kind
of like the weirdest so far like it's
not blacked out like sheep like that
normal like boom I don't even like to be
slapped you blacked out and then they
wake up it's just the next step that's
why that okay my of the she'll make you
feel normal just to completely go the
opposite direction my other ultimate
fantasy is to make a lot of [ __ ]
money
I'm talking like whoa Oh like maybe like
hold on like half a million maybe like
half a million like per year at least
you know I got my own house I got my own
[ __ ] I'm doing my own [ __ ] and I got a
do yet I mean not like a pad I kept a
boy you seize home and yeah I kept boy
and like when I come home like what do
you want you want a glass of wine like
and he knows I'm paying all the bills
and I'm taking care of all the [ __ ] like
I would love to just like because I want
a man that takes care of himself but
like for six months I just want you to
stay at home and be a little [ __ ] and
I'm gonna take care of you and run the
house that's a lot I can't do that
yeah I can't [ __ ] a guy like that but
that's how it would have to power move
it would have to be a temporary thing
but there's so many guys that are so
powerful and in control in their waking
life that in the bedroom sometimes they
like to be submissive
yeah and that's very very very very
common
yeah and so like I like a guy that can
alternate between the both I
unfortunately feel like I'll never be
able to do that but it is no fantasy
well you're gonna make that loan own a
man well my boyfriend's like me he's
very dominant he's you know I could but
I'll bring a check home and be like
later on I'm opposite I love to be taken
care of in small like you know like I'm
that pretty Coulomb daddy yeah dude
that's one of my kinks for like for sure
like and I'm here like daddy issues my
mommy my dad got a good good
relationship but it's just like I like
that small like take care of me like I'm
so helpless and weak without you and
then he just dominates [ __ ] Adam II know
that's [ __ ] hot Gio what else you got
cuz I mean the latex Avenue and that's
like I feel like you got to have
something else um that I want damn I
don't know man I'm trying to get into
that headspace cuz like with Bart and I
because he's just kind of hasn't really
explored a lot sexually like I can't
really go full force cuz then like sex
is only gonna last like [ __ ] a minute
yeah whoa whoa no so like I I'm like
working him like into like getting to my
lover is your mind not really going into
any fantasy stuff because you're just
like stuck in the yeah practical yeah
dude day-to-day because like like it's
weird for me and maybe I feel like you
guys kind of tap into that too like once
I'm in sex mode like I'm a completely
different person
gyeo that you guys know is gone and I'm
just like having a good old time like do
you like getting your hair pulled all of
it all right ladies and hold that
thought because I want to introduce our
sponsor noon so how many of you guys
have been on diets and have been
unsuccessful at them me freaking lutely
every time but noon is dope because they
want to tackle that they're like okay we
don't want people
we don't want them to fail we want them
to stick to it hit the goal and complete
their diet so they're really dope
because they approach weight loss from a
psychological level so they're about
changing habits instead of like telling
you what to eat and how many portions
and all that they're telling you how to
build good habits and to break bad
habits and I think with that alone it's
already it's already a formula for
success so it's it's for better self
care confidence and clothing more energy
and just overall glow like why wouldn't
you want to sign up so Noom is a habit
changing solution that helps users learn
to develop new relationships with food
through personalized courses like how
amazing is that so based on psychology
they teach you why you do what you do
and give you tools to break bad habits
and replace them with better ones
freaking dope where's my backup where's
my backup I'm just listening I'm like
thinking man I'm just sign up for this
right after the death this is great I
absolutely love it so one of the biggest
and most accurate food databases lets
you track meal habits visualize portion
portion sizes and sees calorie density
at a glance so for all of our listeners
just sign up for your trial today at
noon that's n om calm slash b tch so
visit new mom slash b tch to start your
trial today
again that's Noom calm b tch turn your
life around break the bad habits create
new ones do your best but yeah that's
that's where I'm at right now so yeah I
can tap into this whole different brain
space and I'm down for everything [ __ ]
I'll say right now on this show that I'm
like oh I don't think I can do that I'd
probably be down and do that yeah okay
what are some fetishes that you guys
would absolutely not be down just gets
queued up well I could see that now but
I don't know dude I'm not but I get
pooped on like I'm scared about it I
don't know you're not doing I don't know
yeah look I don't want to say never G oh
right we'll hire somebody in full-body
latex to [ __ ] on her
this person it would probably only have
to be bar and then scenario no no scat
no vomiting knowing bodily you know like
I'm all right for come I think if I
vomited that'd be pretty pop yeah I
think so really I think so I think that
would be even turn me on well I think
the only thing the only thing is I don't
like the vomiting I like the if when I
gag on do yes talking to Mike if my eyes
are watering and I'm rolling in yeah and
I'm sure yeah that's my [ __ ] right there
but there's anything for my stomach
coming out not about it smells so yeah
yeah but the drooling dude have you ever
been [ __ ] from behind so hard and
you're screaming so much that you kind
of drool a little bit that she's [ __ ]
hot to show but I do notice when they
shove their dick down your throat you do
start drooling a lot mom oh do they love
that well learn a trick of how not to
gag you hold your your dominant hand
thumb like that what and it keeps you
from gagging try it out when your scream
yeah try it out when you're scraping
your tongue you're watching that little
bag behind your fist in there yeah I
mean a gag reflex exactly so you can
impress them be like watch [ __ ] see
what happens now all the guys are gonna
know this and they're gonna look at all
the chicks hands this doesn't matter all
they want all they want is the dick to
be a half way down the throat yeah and
also if you're a guy and you see a girl
doing this and you know what that means
you're like yes you [ __ ] to worry I
think that might be wrong then because
if you don't guys like hearing a girl
guy cuz I like yeah well it depends on
what he's into if he's down for like
some deep throat and i'ma hold my thumb
if he wants to make me choke imma let go
oh you're like the shampoo function yeah
I just customize its function of dick
it's like I think for like head then
like yeah I do the thumb trick but like
I I think the nicest thing that you can
say to a guy during sex is ouch
so like drying this the night during the
actual intercourse
not too deep don't ya I don't say that
and but honestly I don't say that unless
I'm like for real because I don't want
give you some [ __ ] fake-ass ego bullsh
I think I have shallow [ __ ] cuz I've
always felt like I'm out or you been
taking big ass dick knows we have I
think we have low hanging cervixes Oh
cuz yeah but I mean that's good for me
cuz yeah always good we can take a
variety of dicks and not be with too
worried about it yeah I I made it like a
principle that I would never lie to a
dude about his dick like I'm not gonna
be like oh my god it's a big one it's
not actually that yeah you don't need
that lie in your life yeah that well it
kind of [ __ ] up
it's also like if you say that to a guy
and he knows his dick is not big he's
gonna be like [ __ ] come on yeah yeah
he's gonna be like come on don't don't
play this [ __ ] with me like you know
don't don't tell guy was a small thing
he's got a big dick
be like yeah be honest so good at that
what's an alternative line dan this
feels so good yeah yeah that's true yeah
yeah that's absolutely easy feels good
um so I saw eyeballs on me about my
fantasy but jess hasn't said [ __ ] oh
well I agreed with the the other the
ones from earlier I don't yeah like
gangbangs but you said your craziest one
was um the devil's threesome yeah I
don't really
fantasize a lot about weird things like
I personally just like sex the way it is
and I fantasize more about who it's
gonna be with who do you want it to be
with so Jason Momoa yeah Michael Ortiz
yeah the celebrities obviously or just
people like there's a guy that Gina was
showing us my god she's just like
different people a variety of people
mm-hmm so I'm not crazy like that like
Tang tang my body he could literally
break off my right leg but yeah I think
I don't know why but like it never used
to be a thing for me when I was younger
I would never look at a guy who I
thought was very attractive or hot and
be like I want to have sex with them I
just wouldn't do it and like now for
some reason like if I see a hot guy like
I'm like does this happen when I'm gonna
get you pregnant
you be like guys guys guys yeah just
turn your chest
there is ladies I'm not even that just
yep does that happen though when you're
in a relationship versus not a
relationship
okay so there are guys I don't I don't
know because I've been in relationship
for like well over a year now and like I
there are guys who like a look at now
and I'm like oh he's really hot but I
would never date bit for me I cannot
date like a nine I will just stress me
out hey it'll just stress me out because
I'm I'm confident but I still have some
like self-doubt and stuff because you
think he's too hot for you yeah there's
there's definitely like I need a guy
that like I'm like okay we're good it
like nobody's looking like if he walks
into a room and like I there's people
now that look at my boyfriend and break
their neck and I'm like stop this is a
cease and desist notice from me to you
and like my rose would you fight
somebody I mean thank you oh my god bows
told me [ __ ] died laughing I'm like
I'm down to get into fights I put this
in the group chat seem like I'm down to
get in a fight so I'm never fighting a
black girl because all black girls not a
fight and those goes we fight like our
daddies are gonna come back if we win
white dad yeah no actually my father is
very native Amer have a white mom I have
a black mom I'm wait I'm not why don't
we have white I'm not why oh [ __ ] a
little bit like a little bit of
calendars like like enough that when I
was Ronald McDonald for Halloween
somebody was like that's white face and
I'm like I'm white okay I get asked for
the privilege yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm Italian native-american and
black okay yeah yeah she said that [ __ ]
I [ __ ] lost my mind in the shed yeah
he was gone oh so you're saying about
your man that chicks break their necks
dude no I don't want that well I mean I
just okay so a very this this is from
you personally I don't know if anyone
else relates a very very very very very
attractive guy like in this kind of
isn't site for guys too that don't feel
like they're a [ __ ] perfect ten I
would never date a guy with a [ __ ]
six-pack perfect hair like perfect eyes
chiseled features I wouldn't do it
because I'm not gonna do that to myself
I'm not gonna stress myself out over it
it like I'm like it's just not
attractive to me to be with somebody
that everybody wants I don't know why I
love that because it yeah on the other
hand like if I see chicks looking at my
dude I'm like yeah yeah I wish yeah yeah
for me I'm still a little insecure so
I'm like yeah he might I don't like that
you know like he might be better it's
about might have a chance
yeah it's about knowing like what I'm
struggling with and where my boundaries
are or my limitations are and for my own
mental health I'm like I'm not rich
dated that I respect that I am I
there's V I remember in Vietnamese
culture I was told I was younger they
were like always data got it's a little
bit uglier than you he'll never believe
you
like my grandma straight-up told me that
I was like damn dude that's harshest
book on the topic of fantasies I like
okay so if you can't tell by now for
some [ __ ] reason I like being in zero
control when it comes to getting things
right you know why is that because I
have full control during my life like oh
I can do everything I'd take care of
[ __ ] myself right but when it comes to
sex I like to lose like I have no
control you tell me what to do and I'll
do it
right um one of my fantasies it's a
little bit kind of up there uh get me
ready I don't know I for me it's like an
8 or 9 you said it's up there and this
[ __ ] said 8 or no name ok for me I am
Taiwan TV antenna
I am totally down for my dude to roofie
me I [ __ ] love you like not even
pretend to room each other I want to get
[ __ ] rude like you like I
unexpectedly as an ex of mine he was
like you really want that he's like I
can make it happen but we never think
you're not gonna remember [ __ ] that's
why I'm gonna [ __ ] do you want a video
and record it I'm down but like I want
like no man like I can't move like you
just use me and I can't move and what if
he just doesn't do [ __ ] like you're just
knocked out leaves you alone tells me
that we had crazy session way all right
or he just [ __ ] you for like three
minutes and then came down for that [ __ ]
so for me that's like an eighth or
whatever that no but I think people feel
like [ __ ] after they get roofied I don't
think just maybe like you get xanax yeah
take oh no I can handle my xanax you're
not supposed to do that I'm really
begging for like no control thing down
that's [ __ ] crazy I'm in between both
of you guys alright cuz I was gonna go
opposite side of the spectrum just right
it's like Gina says one thing in there
about sober and I'm like well I want a
man as a pet no so I wait on disclaimer
don't try to [ __ ] roofie me in public
[ __ ] I'm talking like the dudes that
I'm dating not you yeah the ones that
she specifically gives permission yeah
no contract
don't do it yeah um for me back to the
role-playing thing which I've never done
so fantasy is I feel like you're kind of
things that you know we haven't gotten
to do yet right you know the thing that
I wanna do that I haven't done yet
though okay plan i I'm your nurse oh I
would dead-ass do like underworld play
where I was taking advantage of the guy
oh yeah like a misery like I have to do
story I have to do like a checkup but
like
I'm sorry the checkup feels good and so
just keep going so he's like an
optometrist office and you're doing
prostate checks for some reason yeah
if you poked your prostate too hard you
know you think Oh blah I'm gonna have to
check I believe it I'm about to open my
bottle hey yeah I know it really could
and don't worry this this is completely
private no one has to know it's just you
and me and then I bust out the video
camera no I'm just amazing but no I
think it's like it's a thing where like
I on the contrary when I was younger I
never really felt in control of my life
at all and now I have a better handle on
things so I'm very much a switch but I
also enjoy giving somebody that feeling
of not being in control because for men
it's so rare and I found that part of
the reason I enjoy it so much is because
a lot of women are not willing to
deliver that you know and so it makes me
feel more sexy because he's never had
this before a woman's never done this
for him before and I'm like I'm here and
I will take advantage of you that's how
me and Joe's relationship kind of was
like I was kind of dominating him in the
beginning you liked it so much and he
fell in love and you know he just gave
his whole life away from me Tammy give
him that good kitty girl he's so like
soft in the bed the opposites of what
they are in public yeah works the same
way he's a big softy man that's why I
gotta that's why I'm like I'm like I
can't get too crazy and the fantasies or
else I'm just never gonna enjoy sex yeah
yeah you still always propose it because
a lot of time no get down yeah he's down
but I just have to because he's so like
the show-off outlet in that Italy I do
and you have a lot of tricks you know
I'm saying like to bust out at different
times but then if I busted out he's like
it's not even I haven't even executed
the move and he's just like oh [ __ ] I'm
about to bust like
see Wow guys yeah Wow Geo Thanks
okay remember when I told you guys about
how like if we do like lick this come
off me and like we just ate it up yeah
yeah and we made out that's I would
marry the [ __ ] out of him ain't found
one yeah that [ __ ] was dope like after
you did I was like bro I this is the
diamond ring yeah I don't want yeah like
I was like bro this is not even a matter
want anymore I need you dope I own you
hmm and now it's time for a commercial
break
both hey stinky it's time to clean your
ass up Jess what do you got for them
today so we have some some really great
organic deodorant from the ativ less is
more with native they have fewer simpler
ingredients so you know everything
that's in this deodorant yes apparently
aluminum may be linked to some serious
health ramifications so native does not
have aluminum in it and it is still safe
and effective comes in a wide variety of
scents for men and women like yeah
coconut and vanilla which is their most
popular cucumber mint eucalyptus and
mint how like the eucalyptus and mint
yes yeah and I like that there's like a
lot of word-of-mouth backing this up
because there's over 8,000 five-star
reviews and they have been featured on
TV and print like that's how good it is
like oh I'm gonna smell it I know it
smells like candy like be careful
because you're gonna want to eat it like
there's no risk there's free returns in
exchange in the US so yeah
be friendly yeah I know keep it organic
keep it environmentally friendly go with
native you won't regret it and for all
our listeners you're gonna get 20% off
your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use promo code b-tch
at checkout Jeana put that on so we can
title this video gamer tries deodorant
for the first time oh I don't believe
any white stains on
oh [ __ ] it's a stick deodorant that's
the I'm about here it's clear look at
your a stripe alright again you guys
that's 20% off your first purchase visit
a native theater my bad visit native
deodorant dot-com and use promo code
b-tch during check hey you guys brought
that out of me alright have you ever
[ __ ] when someone else has been yes
dude my my ex and I like we went over to
his brother's house that's rude while
they oh yeah it's super rude don't go
[ __ ] dirty and like we [ __ ] so much on
his brothers brothers a piece of [ __ ]
dude we didn't like very much and I am a
squirter sometimes oh yeah we had to
wash my present yeah we had to wash all
the sheets until this day he still
doesn't know well he knows now yeah
you're a squirter yeah yeah oh I mean
like um it really depends I can I can do
it free show like just like really don't
command yeah yes if you dig it out damn
you're a unicorn girl but also it's like
if the dick is real good and he hits the
right spot it triggers it without my
control to you so that's how I know the
dick is real good Wow
yeah I'm like I've accidentally sprayed
myself in the face once Oh bro your legs
a missionary hold on chill for a second
you know what's funny as you're telling
me this I imagine your vagina with the
piece of tissue in it the entire yo cuz
that is one of the most embarrassing
things that's ever happened to me my man
my my former man was going down on me
well he was about to he goes and it was
a piece of toilet paper those tucks in
my [ __ ] and I was just like oh my god
that's almost embarrassing like I wanted
to die right then and there
yeah I've had that on my butt nose in
doggy style Oh
I feel the embarrassment yeah dude I was
just like I'm not horny anymore
hmm I was trying to think of like if I
were to watch a video what video would I
pick porn yeah you know I was I don't
know why I was being censored at all it
was just like I am a squirter and I'm
like when I watch video um what I would
pick and it's weird because I I don't
necessarily think it's a fetish of mine
but I tend to watch like massage videos
oh I've watched some of those those are
hot when they have oils you're such a
loving sensual person it's very
interesting because I don't like that
too but that's out of love because I
love him with bows both makes love I
[ __ ] yeah opposite yeah wait so Jesse
needs to sit on that side yeah I do okay
yeah a lot of [ __ ] I do not [ __ ] dude
you [ __ ] yeah I do it all girl dude
sometimes I want to go slow and I'm like
oh my god you're so perfect we're soul
mates it's not other times I'm like shut
the [ __ ] up yeah Wow yeah I get bored I
guess really yeah yeah I mean I feel
like I'm a little more sensual even with
like or like the first people I be I
guess for me because [ __ ] is like for
kind of a lot of times for people that I
don't know as well like one-night stands
and like early on in the relationship or
whatever be more likely to [ __ ] and then
later on I'm more like oh we actually
love you I've only like made love with
like one person that's how I knew I
really loved him and it was like because
I'm wired a little bit differently
sexually because of how I was raised
um but yeah for the most part I [ __ ]
but then the first time I made levels
like holy [ __ ] friar I cried afterwards
scary yeah my whole life is just gonna
be thrown away to this man right
seriously like like I cried after
whistling holy [ __ ] is that what it is
he's like yeah I think so too because it
liked him for him it was one of his
first few times too and we were like
what the [ __ ] just happened and then I
was like oh [ __ ] I think I love you my
vision was dope yeah yeah after a
session you you were like that's when
you realize
yeah that's really so though yeah and
then like we just sat there and we just
talked about it it was really sweet
yeah I like even when I think about it
now I'm like [ __ ] I might cry yeah the
current dude now I don't have a curtain
oh I mean I don't
oh my bad yeah we don't talk about if
Gina has a current guy or not I always
give that a secret that's true I never
know anything about mix up my stories
like yeah a different time so nobody
ever knows them if I'm dating someone if
I ever do go public with a guy that's
how you know it's like super serious
yeah yeah very true I don't think I've
ever seen you go pop maybe one time
maybe not I don't even know where anyway
mm-hmm
you're a lovemaker yeah when I meet her
I'd be like - sorry here - is she she's
afraid oh no oh no like me cuz me and
TIFF I think we could do both and we
like we'd like buh am I the only
sensitive [ __ ] I'm really not I'm
really not a [ __ ] I love both I think
my sex twin is Nikki like Nikki and I
like yeah we're on the same page into
the same spitting sound for spinning she
doesn't like fingers either yeah yeah
yeah she and I like to be [ __ ] owned
and dominated yeah yeah reduced to
nothing yeah I'm about it yeah like if
my mascaras not running down my face
you're doing it wrong oh [ __ ] damn give
me some tips man cuz I gotta bring this
ship back to Bart where he doesn't kill
me you know me so you want to be common
in are you and me yes if maybe you
already girl I'm gonna be dominant yeah
tame a wild animal Gaea okay yeah give
old tips here cuz I don't want it like
if I die you know it was an act you will
literally crush you through concrete
yeah that's kind of hot yeah do I do i
boy am I asking you you're the sensual
love maker why did you sit be da oh you
want to be dominated yes he wanted to be
dominant never mind I got at the home
and I'm like I got that can of worms but
welcome I think I just really really
communicate what I want
like when I'm dating a guy and we start
getting into the sex site are you say
slap my ass yeah yeah but how do you
tell them like a what do you show him
how hard no I got my ass and I cry okay
okay well Bart's kind of [ __ ] weird
because when I tell you guys I'm
hopeless he doesn't stop first and then
I'm like harder like that you know
that's a good one yeah so he has to
start off soft like the whole part to
start it and start off soft and then you
tell him harder if you want to and then
he'll learn how to gauge it himself
okay what about choking because I think
he only knows how to knock me out like a
clock now
he's holding you down he's like at this
angle you lose consciousness see sounds
like them uh it's really really just
gonna show them like I mean for the most
part it's two hands you press on the
side over here and never on the throat
here cuz that crushes your windpipe so
over here that's a blood choke over here
in the middle that's a wind lights an
air choke so it's more like he grips the
sides only like you it's all about
communicating you've interpreted you've
instructed your dudes how do it yeah oh
I think it's about though instructing
first but then also reinforcing like I
know we're not gonna lie to a guy and be
like oh you have like a big dick if you
don't but I think that if there's
something that you like you can do
nonverbal communication just by like a
moaning a little more like wiggling more
because when a guy does it sometimes
he's like is that too hard but if you
show him like no I really like this like
don't just tell him you got to like
signal it right no I think guys really
like to hear it I think yeah I think
they literally need for you to be like
yes sometimes really I don't know can't
talk so yeah yeah if I can you know
[Applause]
yeah yeah well I'm learning it's just
communicating really like cuz there's a
lot of dudes that I dated bored like
they started off really soft I'm just
like no I think you underestimate me
when I say [ __ ] my ass up you know like
I demolished I see a bunch of
hemorrhoids dude but like it's like you
really underestimate me when I say I can
take a lot and like and then I tell them
like like when we reach that point in
relationship I'm like you can literally
do anything whatever you want except for
like yeah yeah well you can do whatever
you want I am your personal porn star
dad then so whatever you want like just
blade on the table what do you want to
do alright cool let's do that and then
it's usually and it's a lot of guys like
wanna do this I'm like that's it that's
[ __ ] easy let's go guys you're just
like oh let me [ __ ] you hard ya know
like they don't have anything to cut
like it really want anything that crazy
yeah those and then I that means I have
to teach them like hey would you be down
to try this and then usually they learn
kinks along the way that they actually
like I would also like to be your
therapist that takes advantage of you I
just thought about that that to put me
down for that you crying bed every night
sounds like you need to [ __ ] your
therapist to bring some violations well
okay so out of everything we talked
about though what sounds like it falls
into the 9/10 category because we we got
and like I was also just thinking I
heard something
it doesn't ring about for me and you
guys aren't gonna say it's a 9 or 10 but
I feel like for a lot of women maybe it
could be we're just anal fall on a
fantasy oh god like work you know to be
a woman Spanish I think that's a four I
think really that's lower on that okay I
think it's five and down no I forgot
what five was was five the gangbang
I mean we didn't write this down right
out yeah animals like the easy [ __ ] in
beginning we kind of skeezy
oh the earlier [ __ ] like it's like you
experiment and you learn that's simple
so 10 is getting [ __ ] on right yeah we
don't know what is a tenth wait where
where does having a man as a pet fall I
feel like that second thinks what six
there's a sink you Gina owning someone
that took about of four it's not crazy
it's [ __ ] dope you know right yeah
what about Jess what does she think what
do you think
what about owning a guy yeah that's a
sixteen it depends on the people I think
but what is it like uh for me it's
pretty low looks like it Oh who the [ __ ]
am i yeah that's just too easy like but
the tenzin selfish it's words like it
makes people go what the [ __ ] you know
like that's yeah there's something more
dangerous maybe we just don't have an
iron in at ten it's my roofie oh yeah
your Ruby your reviews like a tank
okay okay your roofies a ten [ __ ] yes
unacceptable like especially when we
like threw in xanax and you're like no
not enough I wanna whatever is illegal
she's like I can handle that I want to
not be able to move far beside [ __ ] I
want you to like like paralyze me for a
little bit but I want to be able to move
after please don't break my spine [ __ ]
what's that thing that pregnant women
get yeah that's a girl
really [ __ ] well she wants to be passed
out what's the difference no I want your
eyes will be open and aware and I guess
they'll feel things but I can't really
move like to fight back like I'm like
that I like a drug that the Russians
will give you yourself and like you
can't move but you're yeah or someone
that's torture yeah
yo like I like to not like I like to be
scared right and one of my things is if
I try to crawl away from you you grab my
leg and you pull me back and you [ __ ] me
harder
dude that should do domestic violence is
your king
yeah well beat me up but to be fair also
and I think I've mentioned this before
on another episode it comes from a sense
of like women
we it's kind of a very primitive thing
that sometimes to be objectifies feels
like love you know and like we know it's
not real it like to be like abused or
objectified it's not real it's just I
don't know it feels right to us for some
reason it's just a brush it's a
difference right yeah it is it really is
yeah like I said that the aftercare is
like the big thing that we need
afterwards because there are some people
who do that and they don't do aftercare
and it leaves me kind of [ __ ] up a
little bit yeah that's kind of
traumatized yeah because after all that
crazy [ __ ] and he doesn't like he just
water like oh you're like did he really
feel like that about me so after like I
get [ __ ] abused I like to be like
rolled up in a blanket just be treated
like a little baby
the next time I come over and you're
rolled up in a blanket I'm really trying
to think of a ten here for me I thought
I thought that I thought the [ __ ]
Eyes Wide Shut masquerade party type
thing was that good one up there that's
a ten for you what it's a tech because
this is it these are strangers I know
nothing about I'm just hooking up with
them like that would never do that
that's fair what if we what if we take
Gina's refuses at ten but we're kind of
question marked on the nine and we just
like people in the comments insert
whatever they think they're nine is and
throw it in cuz I want to read oh yeah
because like I feel like we were
supposed to be a little more [ __ ] up
than we really were well know what
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you guys can tell us so
it leave it on an honest account leave
it on your own get ballsy who cares
forgive us but you Thea where design is
I will jump in the comments myself and
up both these things yeah I am too yeah
I want to know some nine cells you're
nine yeah my really button am i boring
no I think I am I think I am really yeah
I did work sorry good I don't I don't
know it doesn't sound like you're boring
you know what I feel like I wouldn't I
don't want to do any weird [ __ ] I
wouldn't have sex with different people
I feel like you would be into toys like
I feel like of a duo with like I don't
do toys at all I use a vibrator on the
clip while he's inside because I should
works every time that's ood oh yeah I've
done that have used a Bluetooth vibrator
that attaches to your panties in public
no yes like that because I needed to
press
know it because your panties are still
like it pushes up against my pennies
aren't that tight yeah oh so you rockin
granny panties no you want me show you
my underwear they're not grand at all
girl
no they have like specific panties for
it where you slide the at the little toy
in and ya sit there and I've done that
before this shit's fun cuz my [ __ ]
vaginas closed like this like you have
to open ya know it you can kind of
separate and just I remember there's
one's hot yeah there is one time we went
clubbing and I was wearing it with my
ex-boyfriend and then like it went off
and I looked over at him but he wasn't
holding it but his guy friend oh no
that's totally fine for me I was like
wait his friend was controlling yeah
yeah cuz he was like you know what
that's actually really hot well you know
him because if it was like that not like
that I feel really weird no no I did
think I backed up has to be someone that
I don't know that's like Joe's like
second third [ __ ] cuts third grade
friend that he hasn't seen in tinium I
wasn't into his friend but he was a
good-looking dude so okay now bad so if
he was like a [ __ ] Shrek lookin
[ __ ] you'd be like it but that's
just cool and that thing is like it's
it's I don't remember what Brandon was
Bush it's like like two something oh wow
good one toys intimidate me because
there's so many and I'm just like
overwhelmed with all the options and I'm
like [ __ ] it forget it I don't want
anything that that is you know what I
really like do you guys like lingerie
I'd love Lunger no bartlett no likes I
think it's boring really same I think
it's easy I love I love it but it's easy
you know when I love to like a silk robe
and like a really like hot lingerie and
I walk out and I'm like right [ __ ] it's
not mmm I know a lot of dudes love that
[ __ ] I like callers and chains I'm down
for that oh that's hot yeah I want that
I remember like there's one time he came
home from work and I had like lingerie
on and I had like a dog collar on a
chain and then when he got into the
house I was on my knees and I handed him
the chain he's like yeah what am I
surprised you know I don't know I like
on suspecting type things so I like like
if like I'm wearing a dress or something
and then like
bend over something like that like the
laundry is too easy because it's too
straight for like I want you to like
kind of guess like I mean like oops have
you ever dated or slept or whatever with
anyone that's really vanilla mm-hmm you
know nope
really vanilla nope no okay cuz I've
been through that and I'm just like so
long I just think what but I take it as
a chance ooh okay he can learn like I
can teach him no I can't do so yeah me
neither I think a part of me just like
if it's like a clean slate and I'm just
like I'm gonna ruin you [ __ ] your [ __ ]
like virgins then yeah your virgin slate
yeah that we don't like I'm gonna [ __ ]
teach you I will [ __ ] your life up that
stresses me out cuz I'm like oh god I
gotta teach this person I can't do it um
how would you guys feel okay scenario
surprise we haven't talked about this
yet it's the thing you're dating a guy
okay
and he one day it's like I want you to
give me a foot job you do it yes feets
not my thing but would you do it for him
you really let him look yeah I mean I
really like him it's weird if I like him
that's easy that's like I'd be like okay
not even anything to me lay on the on
your back and with the [ __ ] knees out
looking dick ulis directly into his eyes
yeah that's easy
really yeah yeah I mean it's easy I
would not be in at all into it at all
but if you dig it I like you that much
I'll do it but it's just not my thing
let me do that sucked on my tail not
about it yeah you like it for me I get
off knowing that my guy is getting off
me too he's getting off hard then I
don't care what I'm doing just is just
me seeing that reaction I'm like oh [ __ ]
I'm a [ __ ] implode right now dude and
I think that's another thing for guys
like don't be afraid to communicate to
your lady like what you like because if
you have a girl that wants to take care
of you wants to please you but also
wants to feel sexy and desired when she
knows she's taking care of you it's hot
to hurt yeah so your fetish just became
her fetish yeah and it shows that you're
really confident and you really know
what you want yeah I love confidence in
the bedroom oh my god I [ __ ] love it
just freak me out that's all me I mean
I'll do it Oh Gina I'm with you I
wouldn't you're on his dick bothers like
just feet period like I just find feet
so unattractive it's like but it's like
one of those like I said if you're in
deep enough praise these balls with your
foot like for fun just like hey like
that's what it looks fine really yeah
just like poke it Oh
ooh I've done that power where it's like
my hands are tied up and I'm like I've
got like I'm trying to show you like oh
my god I want you so bad but I can't use
my hand so I'm gonna use whatever I can
or at dinner under the table yeah he's
sitting across to me I'm done for that
that's like that Gio uses her foot
because when she uses her foot her body
becomes elongated and becomes oh I know
what that is a hand job from [ __ ] the
other room foot job from the bathroom on
you baby don't hate okay
all right ladies so damn how did you
guys like that episode well we're
actually now we're waiting for Gio to
give us sex tips we're ready to eat that
episode I just asked you guys for sex
what the [ __ ] yeah but you asked us
about how you could get dominated
yourself like you said you got a
lockdown you know what's going on we
want to learn from you next time okay
I'm down for that video oh my god yeah
I'm down for that too let's do it so
communicate with us let us know about
how many more like it roofies a 10 tell
us your 9 don't forget to rate the
podcast 5 stars
keep us go up a B and I will hear and
see you next time bye bye [ __ ]